nous sommes au début des années 70 alors
que la grc est impliqué dans une série
d'opérations pour lutter contre le flq
le front de libération du québec et
d'autres groupes indépendantistes
plusieurs moyens utilisés sont illégaux
comme des écoutes électroniques
cambriolage à l' agence de presse libre
du québec
le vol de la liste des membres du parti
québécois l'incendié d'une grange un vol
de dynamite
en 1977 le gouvernement de pierre
elliott trudeau accepte de créer une
commission d'enquêté présidée par le
juge david begg tornade pour étudier ces
agissements de la grc
le juge remet son rapport en août 1980
et conclut que le service de sécurité de
la grc a échappé à tout contrôle dans
les années 70 et que certains de ses
dirigeants ont menti au gouvernement
pendant des années le gouvernement a
décidé de séparer le service de sécurité
de la grc en 1983 robert kaplan de
solliciteur général de l'époque
annoncera la création d'une agence
civils dont l'action se limitera aux
renseignements le scrs comme l'avait
recommandé la commission mcdonald's la
nouvelle loi du gouvernement harper
permettrait désormais au scrs d'aller
plus loin de passer à l'action et j'en
discute maintenant avec david morin
professeur à l'université de sherbrooke
mais c'est mort un bon soir avec ce
nouveau projet de loi est ce qu'on est
en train de recréer ce qu'on a voulu
défaire au fond avec le scrs
il ya quelques temps je pense que pas
tout à fait dans la mesure où
effectivement la loi qui crée le scrs a
quand même mis en place un certain
nombre de garde-fous pour permettre de
mieux contrôler les activités de
renseignement sur le territoire
maintenant je crois quand même que le
projet de loi actuelle soulève au moins
un enjeu important
plusieurs
c'est le premier celui du contrôle des
activités de renseignement et peut-être
que c'est important de rappeler aux
téléspectateurs que la loi sur le scrs
mettez aussi sur pied un comité de
surveillance qui avait pour mandat de
contrôler a posteriori la légalité des
activités de renseignement séquences la
crise garde fous c'est exactement ça le
risque c'est que ça fait dix ans qu'on
renforce évidemment les pouvoirs et les
moyens de ses agences là mais qu' on
nous en dit assez peu sur la possibilité
de renforcer également les capacités de
ceux qui les contrôlent
et vous avez vu il ya quelques jours
dans l'actualité on voyait que le sens
de sécurité des télécommunications avait
écouté un certain nombre de gens qui
étaient tombés dans son escarcelle et
donc les pouvoirs de ce type d'agent
cela sont devenus quand même
suffisamment important pour que je pense
on soulève de manière claire le débat
qui porte sur le contrôle de ses
activités là vous voyez les risques
d'atteinte aux libertés civiles alors je
vois différents risques par exemple si
on donne le pouvoir au scrs d'agir à
l'étranger ok comme le ferait la cia y
aidant évidemment des proportions
moindres alors il faut aussi donner les
moyens à ceux qui contrôlent ces
activités d'enquêté à l'étranger sur le
plan des activités domestiques et là
évidemment on a vu que le scrs va avoir
des moyens de plus en plus importants
d'intrusion et là aussi se pose
évidemment des questions et je ferai une
petite parenthèse aussi dans cette voie
là on parle par exemple de l'apologie du
terrorisme si on fait le lien avec ce
qui s'est passé en france vous avez vu
qu'il ya quelques jours la police a
entendu un enfant de 8 ans qui avait
effectivement fait l'apologie des
attentats contre charlie hebdo
donc je pense que ça soulève quand même
des questions qui nécessitent à mon avis
un débat de fond dans la société
canadienne
et je pense que le gouvernement n'est
pas tout à fait à la hauteur des enjeux
politiques que soulève le débat sur le
contrôle des activités de renseignement
à l'heure actuelle dans un contexte où
finalement le risque est fort qu'il y
ait une instrumentalisation des
questions de sécurité dans un contexte
de campagne électorale et au delà de ça
je dirais même que le problème de ce
projet de loi c'est qu'ils se contentent
sur une partie infime de la
radicalisation qui est le passage à
l'acte terroriste
or la radicalisation est un phénomène
beaucoup plus large beaucoup plus
complexe et pour prévenir la
radicalisation il faut beaucoup plus
d'outils que simplement recourir aux
services de renseignement et à la police
mais est ce que vous craignez que ça
devienne
avec ces nouveaux pouvoirs une sorte de
police secrète le scrs est ce que c'est
ça la crème le meilleur moyen que ça ne
devienne pas une police secrète et je
pense qu'il faut quand même faire
confiance aux agences de renseignement
mais le meilleur moyen que ça ne
devienne pas une police secrète si vous
me permettez c'est précisément d'assurer
un contrôle démocratique et le contrôle
démocratique je pense que ça a été bien
soulever aujourd'hui par les partis de
l'opposition il serait temps de remettre
sur la table le débat de un contrôle
parlementaire des activités de
renseignement au canada qui est
probablement et ça se fait dans les
autres démocraties occidentales
un des meilleurs moyens de s'assurer
qu'un parti au pouvoir qui plus est
quand il est majoritaire il n'est pas
tentée d'instruments tenter
d'instrumentaliser à des fins politiques
les services de renseignement qu'il a
sous sa sous sa direction
très bien merci beaucoup monsieur morin
est venu nous parler
merci
il